no era una tarea fácil la que tenía en
manuel marcó aquí en marsella la de
conquistar el voto de izquierda de todos
los electores de solvi con veloso - jon
que llegó primero en esa primera vuelta
presidencial
aquí en marsella la mano de macon sabía
además que debía convencer el voto joven
para esto se le vio subir a esta tarima
en camisa con las mangas remangadas para
hablar ante unas 4.200 personas que
vinieron a escucharlo por cerca de dos
horas aquí en este parque a manuel marco
no comenzó su discurso criticando a su
adversaria en especial sus posturas
sobre los migrantes sobre los son
musulmanes unos temas muy sensibles en
una ciudad como marsella una ciudad
multicultural y abierta sobre el
mediterráneo luego hermano el mar con
vaso el resto de su discurso sobre la
ecología ese es el tema central no
solamente de este discurso sino dijo que
sería el corazón de su política durante
los próximos cinco años hizo algunos
anuncios como por ejemplo que su futuro
primer ministro sería el encargado de
toda una planificación ecológica este es
un tema de hecho que él retoma del
programa de sondika meloso y también
dijo que habría dos ministros que
estarían de la estrategia en materia de
energía para que francia ya no tenga que
depender de las energías fósiles sino
solamente un desarrollo de energía
nuclear y desarrollo también de parques
ecológicos y de energías renovables de
manuel ama con que hizo hincapié al
final de este largo discurso en que ese
voto del próximo 24 de abril es un
referendo es un referendo de si francia
va a quedarse o no en la unión europea
es un referendo de si francia va a
continuar o no con la transición
ecológica